Hello everybody welcome to Pewdiepie
Everyone's favorite channel.
Your familiest channel everybody
take your family sit down and relax and let's have some fun cuz that's what we do here fun. For your...
Don't say it. Neighbor. What is wrong with me? Today, we're reviewing
Comedy cemetery. That's right
That's where jokes go to die. REDDIT. Ha, get it?
NINJA ART. Get launched through going through a glass window and f'ing die.
Look. Ninja techniques. GENIUS. That's so smart. Dude. Police be like (Whaaa...AH).
I hate everything about this. Fortnite funnies, more like FARTNITE funnies. This is just making me sad.
Meme master Jimmy Fallon. Okay, that's where meme goes to die.
Jimmy Fallon. If memes goes to die on meme review
Well, they're pretty much cremated at Jimmy Fallon. Ron. Hold on are those shoes on sale?
Daniel Radcliffe reacts to Harry Potter memes. AHaHaHaHaHaHa!
Ohhhhh, blessed. Can we get Daniel Radcliffe goes (clap) meme (clap) review? That would be ePiC.
Everyone tweet Daniel Radcliffe right now. I bet you he's gonna be so surprised. I can't wait to look at his face. This image
Never dies on Facebook and Twitter. Let's bury it here.
It's just one of those memes that they just live forever. It's too goddamn funny. People just can't have enough of it.
I never thought I'd actually see one outside of this subreddit. Had your lunch?: wife Husband:
Had your lunch? Wife:
I am asking you. I'm asking YOU. You copying me? You copying ME?. Let's go shopping.
Yes, I had my lunch. (sNicKeRs, punches the wall and screams.)
We accidentally amputated your genitals.
WTF?
Ma'am, you need to calm down!
I need a baptism every time I review one of these memes cuz goddamnit.
trooloolololol.
Write trollolol on the whiteboard when the teacher asked who did it, hold the troll face in front of your face and say
(Makes troll face) and says pRoBlEm?
Laugh
Do it guys. If this video gets 5,000 likes, I will do the troll face.
I love the art as well. How to troll like a boss, ePiC sTyLe. This is (bleeped for demonetization) awful.
I feel sick. I feel disgusted. Why is it so terrible? Is this how people pursue/perceive (can't make up his mind) meme review
I get it now. I'm so sorry. I didn't know, okay?
Happy 10th birthday, son.
Here's a rat. Now go into the woods and fight some strangers and don't come back until you've explored the entire continent.
This is basically the plot of Pokemon. Oh my frickin' GAHsh. I never actually seen this one.
Thanks for explaining the joke (pftya!).
I have an even smaller wireless device that gives me access
To thousands of books and movies. It's a library card. It's a library card!
Oh, I know, I know a joke that needs to be on the comedy cemetery. It's (stammers) this one.
uH, remember when teachers said in school that will never have a calculator in my pockets
uH teachers
uH, you were wrong teachers. Dumbass teachers. Annoying orange is still making videos.
Is that true? Burps and farts and kazoos and pantless pants. Oh god.
I actually have a stage four cancer now.
Speak up, Shellberg. I can't make these goshdarn captions.
Imagine if Fred was still making videos.  Imagine if...
Still here. Why am I still here goddamnit? Have you not made enough money? Uh, yeah. No
I want to buy a house in Japan. Okay guys, (please buy the merch) so I can leave. Oh god, they're still doing it
Huh? All right. Well props to them, you know? Is raywilliamjohnson still uploading? That would be so good.
What happened to him five months ago? My life is dope and I do dope shit
My life is dope and I do dope shit. My life is dope and I do dope shit
My life is my life is my life is my life if my life is so but I don't know shit
My life is dope and I do dope shit. My life is dull but I do don't shit
My life is my life is my life is my life. Okay, so moving on everybody
Let's I think the goal of this video is to move forward and never look
Goddamn it. Look forward and never look back
That's the idea. You are soon my gender. Happy Mother's Day. Sorry, I forgot. You're a Democrat
Us gamer right I died what do you do wait for you to respawn
We're done. She's the one oh
My god, if only I could find the gamer girlfriend
Here's how you know if your if your girl's legit hit him with that. What's up?
qT
Alright i'm done subtitling
You know, you got to hit it a new low for our funny. This isn't our funny Oh, mr. Broccoli
My mother says I should eat you. Well, Timmy you shouldn't listen to her
That actually made me like I hate myself I'm part of the problem Oh God, let's give Mimi
Existential thoughts. I don't know if I can do this anymore. I feel sick. I feel sick
Okay, if you feel sick, don't worry, how do you think I feel when you laugh at something on our comedy symmetry?
Please
Son, if you study today, I will buy you clay season four
Okay, dad three hours later. I'm done. I
like
Me too. Dad
This is torture. The teacher had this up today water h2o drink a lot of water. Let's shake
glug-glug
This is so totally me when I drink a lot of water my water belly goes black
Please enter valid email address Viper five four three two one zero
Yahoo! Yes confirm. Yes. That is my email
Legend
Legendary epic win I bet I can get you to say red. Okay, try it. What color is the sky?
blue
Told you I could get you to say blue. No you said red
Boom, my mind has been blown. He just got trolled. I feel troll. Just reading it. I feel the same way
Hey cat. Yeah, can you walk like me?
Ahahahahaha. Yes, not bad when I
Really appreciate the framing of this meme adding wind underneath with a knife funny
watermark, that's how you know
You know, you gonna have that your enemy
And it will automatically make it better. Just win
Epic win dissolve egg shell off with vinegar and it will become a naked ed deck and found directions to confusing
Ceiling fan. Oh, yeah, these goddamn awful comments that always get tough voted for some reason. They're not funny
There's always some goddamn ass
Let's never seen it before and they're like ha that's funny dick and ceiling fan all thumbs that up stop
You're part of the problem. I'm sick of it what other comments like that big?
It's some iPhone cookies to trick cops into pulling me over then. I just take a bite and ask if cookies are against the law
Dude, that's Savage. That is so freakin Savage trolling the cops epic style
Come on Jake. Hey, man, what's up? Just converting oxygen into carbon dioxide, you know the usual
WTF man school's out. Why are you still doing science breathing Jake? I'm breathing. You didn't know
carbon dioxide comes from your pussy
You didn't know that you can dumbass you didn't know salt would sodium chloride, you know
Salt would sodium sulfur you dummy. You can reason want to have some fun go to Starbucks
Okay, this is a really cool trick guys. I think you'll enjoy this
Go to Starbucks and order and when they ask the name get this
Okay, get this say Trump
Okay, they will be forced to yell out Trump and everyone in the store will start crying
And I did it this morning, and it was awesome
Rolling libtards, it's awesome. If you wanna have some fun
go to Starbucks and say I have an ar-15 if
Anyone goes near the door. I'm gonna shoot
It will be awesome. I did it today
I'm losing it
Why do we see lightning first and hear the sound after a couple of seconds gaming Bible lag?
I guess teachers don't know about Lange
That's when the game isn't running as fast as it should be that's when your processor is having an interconnection
Bet you didn't know that stupid teacher
You're supposed to be a teacher that teaches stuff
but you don't even know the game our metrics and rules Emma Watson had to quit college because every time she
Answered a question. Someone said three points to Gryffindor
trolling
level
Gryffindor trolling level King Gryffindor that's like top level
That's right about b-movie trolling or a genome level trolling gary fiend or trolling makes people quit school
God, damn me Emma Watson. That's why you dumb. That's why you have that dumbass face. That's why you're a feminist
Do you have a girlfriend set? Yeah dad nice
Where is she from from a different nation or really? Which nation my
Imagination trolling dance ethnic style. Hey, thanks for accepting my request
I like you be my girlfriend. I'm 14. Oh
Hey, so you 89?
Patrons level over ninety nine nine nine thousand. It's over 9000. It's over nine
Today's topic is
Photosynthesis. Okay, ma'am. So tell me what is
Photosynthesis today's topic. Give me sunglasses
get fooled
This is epic. Do you know that's how these can meme started this goddamn guy? Who even is he?
Who is he supposed to be just some guy with a dumbass hair and hair and sunglasses?
Yeah, why is Robert Downey jr. There dentists in China be like let's just put Robert Downey jr. In there
You know what? Let's put Robert Downey jr. In every single goddamn meme that ever existed. Alright if Donna- Robert Downey jr
Is not in a meme
It's not it's not a meme if there's not a meme and for the record Robert Downey jr. It's not that great
Okay, everyone keeps holding him to him as a standard of cool or badass people really. He's just a fucking hack. Okay, that's right
I'm the first one to say it
He's cringy and he's not funny and he's it's as if he's playing a character outside
He's goddamn Marvel. Bullsh is that if I'm acting like PewDiePie outside opieop. I
Epic did you see you just threw that expensive watch away. What a freaking savage dude savage level Robert Downey jr
This is actually a found object
Okaying some scavenging of a folk art buddy of mine and we run up working this into a living art piece
Oh, that was was horse. That's relay. This is a Jaeger. Oh
You just made that up like dude. He just made that up on the fly. Holy hell dude
What an absolute maniac who just makes shit up on the flying like that?
Like what? How do you even do that trolling level Robert Downey jr. You know what from now on Robert Downey jr
Is gonna be here in the video? Cuz I think that will just make the video better. I don't know
Why you guys it's cyber Brad actually do that like I want him there
It doesn't that make the video better. I think so. Well, nothing could make it. This is even worse. Oh
by the way by
btv guys
By the way, by the way, but the way do you know that by the way?
uganda knuckles, so savage, what the hell was comedy back in
2012 or 10 2015 like what furries are so gay
All they do is have sex we in weird animal costumes
Ok. Well that looks kind of cool. I
Take back everything like a fur dude
I'm referring out guys not because I want to because
I'm trolling lib tarts epic style. Join me my fellow furries
Damn markiplier's password be like password my height error
Password too short get it
originated a joke by octan racer and
robo jelly Trek
Don't steal this joke or octan razor and robo jelly tech are gonna come for you
This video has been sponsored by markiplier. Someone give this guy an Oscar
Give him an Oscar. I cant tell if trolling, thats the problem with this
like three people will get this but it's worth it
Pencil oh my god. No one will understand this joke
Only three people in the world. Can you imagine? Oh my gosh
Like what does a pencil mean? How was I gonna help him? Oh my GOD (he's literally losing his mind)
Oh, I've seen this talk about a what the heck moment. Let's get this thing viral
Talk about a what the heck moment. Why is the cow doing that guys? Can we get this viral?
Can we get this video viral? Can everyone tweet James Charles's video and he will be like a total
What the heck moment if we can get this viral by everyone tweeting James chalasis. What the heck?
That would be a total walk the heck
Well, I wish I could see his face phone call home and elementary...why you gotta call my mommy though middle school, man
if that gives wrong number high school, I don't give a mmhf bihhh
ill call my damn da i dont give a fuhhhh man ill call my gah dam selff
cant tell if racist im jus reading it out
Okay
Oh dude
gamers will understand this meme if
You're a gamer smash like in this video just so I can know if you and understand its mean or not
I don't get it man eats steak in front of vegan on TV crazy reaction
savage
Someone give that man an Oscar
I've seen the thumbnail of this but I've never actually seen the video. You're a vegan
I'm really it's really hard because I don't have I told you I'm from Wisconsin. Okay, and
Cheese, it was like one of my favorite things see how that looks pretty good. That's a little rare medium rare
yeah thats a nice dead animal- dead cow hanging off your fork
Bad that I'm eating meat if you go hunting that's a totally different story right the bloods on your hands right now
You're kind of just enjoying the benefit and the Bloods on someone else's hand. oh my god. I actually agree with the vegan, but the
This happened with 2018. How did we end up like this? I wonder if there's like a pewdiepie one. Yeah
Don't be racist be like pewdiepie. He's Swedish speaks English
dating Italian girlfriend and acts bl***
Don't be racist be PewDiePie guys the least racist person on the goddamn planet BOOP. Oh my god
It's Robert Downey jr. Trolling level. Tony Stark. How's it going, Tony?
I have this headache that comes and goes Steve walks in hi Tony. There it is again
Tony's freaking stark is so freaking epic, thumbs up this video for Tony Stark. Thank you guys
Finally, we have proved that meme review isn't really the place where memes goes to die. Actually. You're right god damn it
Actually, it's wherever Tony Stark is. Okay, you want pyramids? We got him?
Oh, you're into castles, huh? We got you covered baby. You want some pets easy?
We got it all
This game is still relevant. God damn it